I personally really dislike it when I'm
on a date with a girl and she says or
she relates to me that she really likes
black men or that she exclusively dates
black men in my head I've already extra
oh yeah
for me it's immediately over from the
snide yeah so what do you think about
dude it's black guys guys yes somebody
liked me I hate dudes like this guys we
just giggle and laugh at the idea of
other races being interested in them on
the purpose of their skin that's a Sam
[ __ ] I'm waiting for you to do the
whole minstrel show where you put
lipstick on your mouth that is crazy bro
so you like black guys guys like me no
it's cuz dudes like this is the reason
why these girls so comfortable single
out is weird if they're really really
cool like real easy to get along with ha
ha
[Music]
they are really good at party like
really like dance a lot really good
moves and really cool inking I'm gonna
try to keep it as brief as possible but
when you when you fetish I someone you
erase their individuality yeah and so
when you come into a date yes
acknowledge the fact that you know me
being black is a reality but if that's
like the sole reason for which you're
open to dating me then that's a problem
because you're coming in with
preconceived notions of who I'm going to
be you are trying to attribute my
personality to those things and then you
were trying to fall for that idea rather
than Who I am and it's stifling and it's
annoying because I may not fit all the
stereotypes or whatever you think a
black man is supposed to be every sum it
up is more like that
oh you're black I love watermelon you
know what I mean swag I'm sure I'm not
mad at that and I don't like watermelon
that's ironic
I don't like watermelon no great Jim I
don't like melons I don't like water
I don't like seeds oh no you know I
don't like watermelon well this is
cartoons to watch as a kid well this guy
would eat a watermelon
bbbb gay what is that I remember that's
Regis yeah
it's eating the watermelon just living
out like it's like I don't know what
that cartoon was that's um that's not
like like no but it's what Disney
used to do this menu Luda to do back in
the days that's what they used to do and
it was just like all this to say Percy I
really dislike it I find it really weird
when like when she's like you have the
black ass just like so cool and just
like it's gross it's a X it's a cross
and I know guys who play into it they
love ya because for them they already
know they got it in so they're just
happy to get some pumping but and
someone might say well what do you say
to black women who only wanted a black
man it's not the same thing no I think
the difference between wanting to
preserve certain culture held to
carriages or like wanted to preserve a
certain culture so me wanting that my
partner having that reflected my
children is not the same as a white girl
saying I want to date black guys cuz
they dance very well and they got big
it's not the same thing right cuz then
you just become a trophy in that
person's life what do you think people's
perception is a black minute general
people were scary were threat yeah we're
crazy we're cool were strong that's a
general see the thing that I see yeah
and so when they find out like black men
like anime they're like what why would
you guys when it's actually super
comments a lot of black guys like anime
but you know we don't give people that
space to be individuals or to be in two
different things yeah cuz I'm just I
really dislike it and and I think a lot
of girls say it and they don't realize
how gross it is yeah and in my head I'm
just like but I would never think of
being with a white woman because she's
white is John John I that's really made
my day guys you know so I think you guys
have I don't wanna say like black guys
are really good in bed and also enabling
her for sure and the girl is just a
product of social media and everything
you know that's that the same thing I
hear this [ __ ] I hear slavery all over
again it's good feet strong I would like
to see you know what our hand children
look like who says that there's people
who fetish is light-skinned people
oh yeah it's like mixed people are
fetishized to an insane yet more
oh my god you're a black person with the
blue eyes and it's not you who are like
a rare Pokemon yeah and if I'm black
it's not a fetish sighs about black
people is do you know what makes me
think about thing makes me think about
those black girls who got pictures was
like kids in Africa with white guys who
feel that way about Asian women yes yeah
that's the same thing yeah you don't
realize it but you are you racing that
person's individuality you are not
seeing them for who they are but your
perception of what their group I didn't
gifts to that person yeah so I just want
to make you short little video about
that to have that topic we wanna know
what you guys think what are your
thoughts when someone tells you that
they're into people of your race does it
make you more attracted or less
attractive we want your input so leave
that below
[Music]
you